vielen dank für den moment und dem
auswärtigen amt hat man zwar die
vorhersehbaren entwicklungen in
afghanistan nicht im blick gehabt dafür
hat man die zeit gefunden andere zeichen
zu setzen ja und unter diesem motto
zeichen setzen wurde ein leitfaden für
die männerdominierte behörde entwickelt
der unbewusste vorurteile gegenüber frau
bewusst machen und damit ausmerzen soll
jeden monat gibt es jetzt ein paar tipps
um frauen nicht zu diskriminieren und in
ihre karriere zu behindern dagegen ist
natürlich grundsätzlich überhaupt gar
nichts einzuwenden der zeitpunkt lässt
es halt nur etwas unglücklich aussehen
aber wir können uns ja mal ein paar
tipps anschauen er gerne irgendwann
bedanken
reflektiert und hinterfragt rollenbilder
es da eine forderung an die männer macht
euch euere unbewussten vorurteile
bewusst also damit fangen wir mal an
bevor wir zu den fortschrittlichen väter
ankommen unbewusste vorurteile findet ja
ganz interessant weil es gibt ja in der
tat immer einen großen unterschied nicht
nur bei männern aber
zwischen selbstwahrnehmung und
fremdwahrnehmung ich zum beispiel bin
immer der meinung dass ich jemand bin
der frauen total respektiert und den
richtigen umgang hat geht auch gar nicht
anders ich habe zwei sehr starke frauen
zu hause meine frau meine 25 jährige
tochter da komme ich gar nicht zum zuge
kommen da dominieren zu können
trotzdem war es aber so und das können
wir glaube ich ganz offen und
transparent ruhig mal sagen als wir
beide uns hier kennengelernt haben ja
erst vor kurzem für diese neue sendung
hattest du schon den eindruck dass ich
da vielleicht nicht matschig aber schon
irgendwie dominant mache ohne das stimmt
also genau macho war es nicht gerade
aber dass du in so alten rollenbildern
schon ein bisschen festhängt es ist
jetzt krass formuliert aber ich glaube
das war einfach eine andere zeit bis 20
jahre älter als ich nur da hat man
einfach der mann hat gearbeitet die frau
war zu hause hat sich vielleicht noch so
ein
natürlich ist es das was man auch
vorgelebt bekommt von seiner ich glaube
es ist eher so ein gefühl in der tat 20
jahre älter du bist 39 bin 58 und man
kommt er sofort in seine kleine
väterliche rolle hinein irgendwie die
ist dann vielleicht gut gemeint aber
irgendwie auch fehl am platz schauen wir
uns den nächsten tipp man seit
fortschrittliche feta und entwickelt
eine gesunde work sameli balance dass
ich finde wirklich ein thema war also
ich finde das muss jetzt einfach in der
heutigen zeit gegeben sein kann einfach
gar nicht mehr sein dass man von den
vätern oder jetzt von meinem mann in
diesem fall einfach nicht die
unterstützung vorgearbeitet er arbeitet
hier wir sind jetzt im moment wenn ich
arbeiten muss er natürlich zu hause sein
das heißt muss er ist natürlich auch
gerne zu hause und auch für die kinder
dar weil ja wer soll es sonst machen und
ich finde es auch ganz wichtig zu wissen
dass er sich in dem moment wo ich mich
halt hier konzentrieren muss auch zu
hause kümmert und alle sind gut
aufgehoben auch die forderung mehr
elternzeit zu nehmen dass meine eltern
ich verstehe diese plakate nicht weil
ich verstehe die panikmacher nicht also
dass man überhaupt noch darauf hinweisen
muss jeder dritte mann nimmt aktuell in
deutschland elternzeit 79 prozent der
männer wünschen sich mehr zeit mit der
familie und ein drittel der männer
würden sogar gerne teilzeit arbeiten
also wir haben doch super
fortschrittlichen sättigen amt nicht der
fall zu sein also ich finde jeder dritte
mann nimmt jetzt schon elternzeit 79
prozent wollen dass das private sollte
in meinen augen in dem fall privat
bleiben es ist doch eine entscheidung
zwischen mann und frau und ich finde man
muss doch zu hause klären wenn ein
drittel der männer sagen sie würden
gerne in teilzeit arbeiten wir müssen
sie zu hause sagen so könntest du dir
auch vorstellen vollzeit zu arbeiten
aber das ist doch ein privates problem
das muss doch jetzt nicht auch noch der
start am besten übernehmen den männern
beizubringen wie sie fortschrittliche
väter sind und ich finde die statistiken
sprechen doch gar nicht so gegen uns als
land oder trachten deutschland aber ich
glaube viele männer sind tatsächlich
auch noch nicht dazu bereit das wollte
ich gerade sagen ich glaube viele männer
haben da auch einfach eine blockade die
denken wenn ich jetzt mal im arbeitgeber
sage ich würde gerne in elternzeit gehen
die gucken die mich dann an die werden
zum teil auch glaube ich schief
angeguckt und dann macht man es besser
nicht mehr findet jeder dritte mann
wenig also ich hab die zeige sind habe
gedacht wow jeder dritte mann in
deutschland und elternzeit so schlecht
ist das gar nicht würde sagen die hälfte
sollten wir schaffen müssen wir als ziel
haben ich habe mir das nächste benutzt
eine geschlechtergerechte
sprache erhöht die sichtbarkeit von
frauen und nicht wie lehrern personen
also menschen die sich weder als männer
oder als frauen fühlen das ist jetzt
natürlich an das große thema wo wir
mitten hineingeraten wir wollen es nicht
zu sehr aufregen ja ich weiß ist auch
dahinter aber
[Musik]
aber sandra in der tat da gibt es ein
paar sehr interessante tipps auch dabei
ganz genau jetzt ist es nicht mehr drin
ich habe es auch nicht
das ist dass das ganze ein wirklich sehr
sehr verrücktes beispiel das ist nur zu
den gender lexikon das wohl wird in das
man mal geschickt denn dann heißt das
und da wird empfohlen statt spionen
jetzt
auskundschaften person zu sagen ich
meine wie schwierig ist dass das ist
allerdings ein guter gag auskundschaften
personen müsste john le carré
beispielsweise seinen berühmten thriller
der spion der aus der kälte kam um
tauchen in die aus kunstschaffende
personen die aus der kälte kam ok
grundsätzlich meine haltung jener bevor
du dich auf rechts und um das klar zu
machen ich finde es durchaus wichtig
dass man darauf eingeht es ist natürlich
dann wieder wie das immer so ist an den
auswüchsen übertrieben aber manchmal ist
es ja auch so dass man erst in extreme
geben muss um dann hinterher im
mittelmaß zu finden weil man ja von ganz
unten kommen ich finde erst mal dass
dieses trainer aus einer ganz tollen
bewegung entstanden ist die bewegung
dahinter ist ja wir müssen uns kümmern
alle müssen sich angesprochen fühlen das
ist etwas super positiv ist dass die
menschen sich darüber gedanken machen da
bin ich bei dir finde ich ganz toll mein
problem ist für mich ist sendern anti
feministische und der grund das ist für
unsere sprache schlecht das hört sich
blöd an es wäre für mich kein grund
sprache verändert sich aber warum müssen
wir im jahr 2021 jedes mal darauf
hinweisen du bist eine frau du bist ein
mann ich möchte gerne autor sein ich
möchte gerne kolumnist sein und letztens
wurde ich als gäste eingeladen und da
muss ich ehrlich sagen thomas war es für
mich ein affront weil ich gedacht habe
also nee lass mich bitte gast bleiben
und ich sender auch nicht und habe schon
oft mit ich schreibe bücher und dadurch
einmal den fall dessen verlag einfach
mein buch durch geändert hatte im
lektorat ich wollte es nicht damals bei
27 und da habe ich gemerkt wie blöd der
verlag mich eigentlich danach fand dass
ich das nicht wollte und das ist mein
problem mit dem sender aber ich bin
beide die entwicklung dass wir uns
gedanken machen wie können wir mehr
menschen miteinbeziehen ist ganz
großartig
[Musik]